okay I'll uh thank the other organizers
for inviting me to talk um and uh so the
the title of the talk is I think I think
it got changed to something like
prospects for a Quantum PCP theorem um
I'm actually quite pessimistic that it
that this holds but uh I'm less
pessimistic Than I Used to Be and so in
this talk I want to talk about um what
what such a theorem would be but also
sort of some ideas many from topology
that give us some idea of how we could
at least try and uh maybe prove it and
at least also prove some weaker
conjectures that I'll mention so I want
to start by talking a little bit about
some some classical problems and I'll
explain what this PCP theorem is so let
me just give um a list of examples
suppose we have um a one-dimensional so
let's just start by writing some
classical systems and suppose we just
have a one-dimensional system you know
spins on a line and it's some classical
coupling each one couples to the
neighbor and so at each site you know um
there's maybe not just you know two
states but three four some fixed order
one dimensional thing and let's ask what
happens in this case classically um this
table is going to be quite useful I'm
going to sort of do a series of of
examples by to argue by analogy and a
little bit to motivate some later stuff
that happens and uh let's ask also first
what happens if the hamiltonian is just
to give an example the
ferromagnetic ising model so on each
site there is uh two states
sometimes called spin up and spin down
and the hamiltonian just says that
neighboring states would like to be in
the same state so if you study this
hamiltonian um what you find is that
there's long range
order at zero
temperature so you know either at zero
temperature you either have the state
all spins up or all spins down but no
long range
order at uh any any non Zer temperature
any nonzero temperature so this is just
sort of standard old result in physics
and also if instead of considering the
pherom magnetic ising you consider some
uh we could call it a spin glass
hamiltonian but just some sort of
completely arbitrary interaction between
nearest neighbors so there's some
interaction between this Spin and the
neighboring Spin and this Spin and the
neighboring Spin and so on chosen in
some way it's actually quite easy to
find the exact ground state this is an
algorithm known in many fields I guess
as dynamic programming transfer Matrix
and so on but it's quite easy to find so
uh exact ground
state uh ground state is easy is easy to
find when you go to this when you do an
arbitrary hamiltonian now let's go to 2D
let's see what happens when we go to two
Dimension so you have say a square
lattice if you now consider the
ferromagnetic ising model on a square
lattice there's actually long range
order if you do it in thermal
equilibrium for some temperatures T less
than some critical temperature
temperature and this critical
temperature is is strictly greater than
zero so there's really some temperature
at which a phase transition happens so
you have a long range order below a
certain temperature um but now finding
the exact ground
state is hard it's hard to find the
exact ground state of the system and
this is classic result that is it's it's
NP hard to find the exact ground state
of of such a system if I have arbitrary
interactions of course not for the
ferromagnetic ising but if I have sort
of arbitrary interactions between
neighboring spins on a 2d Square lettuce
this is a hard problem um but although
the exact ground state is hard let me
know if this is hard to read um the
approximate
approximate is easy and what do I mean
by saying that the approximate is easy
well um suppose you want to approximate
the ground state energy to a constant
fraction you want to get the ground
state energy to an accuracy of 1% so so
roughly speaking you do the following
you know know you have your your
two-dimensional Square lattice so you
have your your couplings like
this okay so you know it's some large
Square lus so I'll just draw some big
box to indicate the whole system you
know so there's many sites in here and
what you do is you take your system and
you break it up I'll just erase the
square lce you break it up into cells of
size let's say little L by little L
squares of this size and you ignore all
the interactions on the boundary of
these patches all the interactions along
this line or along this line and so on
and you exactly solve the system in
every single one of these patches so by
doing this you get a reasonable
approximation to the ground state how
good are you on energy well you've
missed all these terms all the terms on
the boundary here and they represent a
certain fraction of the system size what
fraction well if the whole system has
Dimension capital L the fraction of
terms that live on these boundaries is
of order little L over capital L so that
gives you some estimate of your
approximation so you know where Epsilon
is the the relative accuracy to which
you compute the energy if you do it this
way this is sort of roughly your your
approximation accuracy you you know
there's some technical details of
certain of the bonds are stronger than
certain the other bonds and then you
have to pay attention to where where you
put these Cuts but this is a general
idea and how hard is it to do this well
to solve in one of these patches I can
just exhaustively enumerate all the
states in the patch and it takes a time
that's exponential in the patch size but
if Epsilon is some fixed number like 1%
then this patch size is some fixed value
and so um this the size will be a
constant will be will be linear in the
system size is that clear so some people
are looking a little bit confused so I
want to make sure I think maybe you just
meant one over little uh this is um
Epsilon is little L over uh uh yes of
course of course sorry thank you yeah
one over little L is what I meant to
write um yeah yeah so the the accuracy
would be one over little L thank you
yeah um one over little l so as we make
this little L bigger I guess that's what
I said in words that if you sort of have
Epsilon is 01 you need your patches of
size sort of 100 yeah of course it's
that's what so so it's it's actually
easy to approximate the ground state if
your notion of approximation is
approximation to a constant factor to
you know a something that's extensive
proportional to the number of sites and
um similarly I'll just mention back on
this side of the the ferromagnetic ising
table there are
low energy
states
without long range order exist and what
do I mean by this I mean I can write
down a
state which has relatively low energy
but where if you look at the expectation
value of two randomly chosen spins this
is for the ferromagnetic ising model
it's quite close to a half or I mean you
know they're they're sort of equally
likely to point in the same way as
opposite ways and the way you do it is
easy you just take all the spins in this
patch and point them up and all this the
spins in this patch and point them down
and so on and if you take two randomly
chosen spins they're sort of equally
likely to come from the up patches or
the down patches so the correlation
between two far away spins is small so
you have only uh no long you have no
long range correlations and yet this
state also has low energy it has again
the same one overl energy um and then
the last example if we go to um as Aram
was talking about expander graphs so if
we put the system on an expander
graph so you have some graph for the
interactions so you know each site
couples to a few sites Each of which
couples to a few more and so on and it
kind of looks locally like a tree but
grows outwards we can again consider
what happens and one of the remarkable
things is that when we go to the fer
magnetic ising
model low energy states without long
range order do not exist if you have
good enough expansion properties and you
have talking about low enough energy so
no low energy
states
states without long range order and what
do I mean by
that well so you take your expander
graph and you're going to assign some of
this spins to be up and some of the
spins to be down and if we want to have
um no long range order it shouldn't be
that uh sorry we it should be that sort
of 50% of the spins are up and 50% of
the spins are down rather than you know
say 100% of the spins up or 90% of the
spins up so sort of half should be up
and half should be down so what we could
do is we could uh you know color each of
the sights of the graph or in fact let's
just color one set of sites we'll color
the set of sites where the up spins are
so you know so maybe the up spins will
be these sets of sites like this and
then the down spins will be the sites
that I haven't colored so you pick out
some set of vertices which will be the
the up spins and this will be roughly
half the size of the graph by
construction half the vertices will be
these up spins and if you have certain
expansion properties um it for for for
many of these graphs you still have
expansion even when you take a set
that's half the size of the graph and so
you know that the number
of sites the number of edges which are
on the boundary between an up Spin and a
down spin like this one is again
proportional to the number of UPS spins
so the the energy will be proportional
to the number of SES so as soon as I say
that I have have no longer range order I
have also no low energy yeah so your
title is classical but you are kind of
sneaking in some Quantum there I I don't
think I put any Quantum there I'm going
to go Quantum in a second where where is
that Quantum it sounds Quantum because
you are talking about spins and oh no no
so so just say that no no when I call
them spins it just means there are two
when I say classical it just means there
are two states zero and one or up and
down yeah but but in the in the that you
are talking about the pherom magnetic
model and that could have like a
entangled ground no no no no no no no
this is this is a classical model this
is a classical hamiltonian that is the
some the terms in the hamiltonian are
just to use quantum terminology szi szj
but they all they all are diagonal in
this product basis so they just are
whether a spin is up is is zero or one
or up or down you know if you prefer
I'll call them bits if it if it makes it
sound less Quantum I'll call them bits
okay you know so this this thus far is
completely classical you a question in
the
back so what's thetical temperature you
in whe the long range order stops at 2D
so it stops already you know you given
examples where it stops
but um well so for the 2D Square lce you
can actually calculate it exactly um
this is a work of uh well Kramer and van
and then later on Sager's exact solution
um they they previously knew the exact
temperature but there's also an argument
called the argument which is much more
general which lets you prove it even for
lates where you can't solve it exactly
um so uh
2 yeah I mean it's not a tiny number
it's actually fairly High yeah yeah it's
a lock of one yeah um so so I think I
think I will give maybe a little more
intuition in a bit as to why it's non
zero uh when I talk about some stuff but
but yeah it's it's it's a number that's
that's known exactly you know
mathematically exactly is not
small other questions
okay okay good so I so I made this table
this was the classical setting now I
want to make a table in the uh in the
quantum context so I want to talk about
some uh Quantum
models oh yes yes yes of course yeah I
forgot the most important one yes thank
you I got I I got distracted for a
second so the most the most important
thing and this is this is to my mind
like one of the most amazing things that
computer scientists have ever uh told
physicists perhaps is that
approximate is hard at this point
finding the approximate state is hard if
you even want to if you take some and
this is the PCP theorem uh so if you if
you have some
some fixed size alphabet on each of
these sites and some local interaction
um if you even want to approximate the
energy to a certain Factor say you know
1% this is this is an NP hard problem
you know I don't know exactly what the
exact factors of approximation are at
which this becomes hard this will depend
upon what classif of hamiltonian if you
consider but it's really hard to even
get a finite you a fixed nonzero
accuracy of approximation which is which
is kind of remarkable and it's really
special to the fact that we do it on an
expander graph because this trick of
cutting it into patches and saying I
solve in every patch this would work in
2D would work in 3D would work in 40 and
so on but here it doesn't work because
if you try and cut it into little
segments and solve on each segment you
find that there's just as much stuff
between your patches as there is in the
patches so you make a large
eror yeah so now I'm beginning to wonder
what you mean
byne icing or maybe you said and missed
yeah I mean I'm basically trying to keep
two columns this column is uh in every
case there's some alphabet of sites on
here and in this column there's there's
only two states on each site up and down
or zero and one and the hamiltonian is
just penalizes it if they're not
pointing in the same direction they're
not in the same state and this is if we
consider a totally arbitrary
one okay so some Matrix of some some
Matrix to describe Wiis yeah so in this
case it's just some arbitrary Matrix for
PA wise inter yeah whereas in this case
it's specifically the ferromagnetic
ising model that says that says we
penalize them if they don't point the
same way right that's why I have two
columns maybe
ion yeah no I'm I'm drawing a line to
separate this column from this colum it
was the horizontal purple
line okay oh yeah said I drew a line
here but not there good okay yes I was
there another question D yeah so so
you're saying in 2D that there is long
range order at low temperature yes but
there exist uh low energy states without
long range order how does it can you
explain yeah yeah I mean these these
states are quite special right I sort of
very carefully put where I put the
defects so just that they're rare yeah
yeah they're rare entropy is is sort of
crucial in a way to getting the long
range
order yeah um so is do mathematical
definition of what long range order
means or how should I think of in this
context let's say um in this context for
meeting I'm going to make an analogy of
the quantum thing but to make all these
a statement that fits with all these is
to say let's look at I'll use the
quantum notation szi szj so I andjr
sites and uh sum them over all I and J
and divide by the number of SES squared
and so SZ is plus or minus one and ask
whether this quantity is uh zero or
something sort of order one over n away
from zero or whether it's a number
that's you know fixed away from zero
founded circly founded away from
zero is is okay okay um okay good so now
let me make this uh the the analogous
Quantum
table now in
Quantum we don't know too much about
this column kind of the interest is in
the quantum PCP is whether we can do
much about this column but let me talk
about sort of a column that in a way is
the analog of this pherom magnetic ising
model column so what I want to talk
about is I want to talk about the toric
code or generalizations of the toor code
various forms of this um this is a
particular Quantum hamiltonian
um that uh is studied a lot it's a it's
a good example of a hamiltonian uh with
topological order and I'll I'll try to
State what that is so let's let's start
with the two-dimensional Tor code the
table is now going to start in two
Dimensions right rather than in one
dimension for things to be interesting
so in the two-dimensional Tor code what
we have here is we have a
lattice the degrees of freedoms actually
live on the bonds of the lattice here
and on each Bond there's a spin and the
hamiltonian has two terms there's a sum
over all the pletes of the hamiltonian
and it's a
product of all the bonds that are in
that plet the SZ on that Bond and then
also a sum over all the vertices a
product over all the bonds that are
adjacent to that uh vertex and then the
SX on that that one so the hamiltonian
is the sum of these two terms um
probably some people are extremely
familiar with this and some people are
not as familiar with this um the
particular property I'm going to talk
about that it has is a property called
topological order so this thing has a
remarkable property called topological
order uh
order at T equal Z but no topological
order for T greater than zero and also
no topological order for low energy
states so what does it mean topological
order this remarkable property of this
hamiltonian what it means is that um if
you could take the ground state there's
there's many definitions and I'm going
to be quite loose for most of this talk
about epsilons except for the few places
where I give like the the interesting
conjectures where then I'll try and put
the epsilons in so that you can you know
you know those will be stated precisely
but of it I'm just going to be due to
shortness of time and so on I'm going to
be quite loose about epsilons um so what
does it mean topological order to Define
topological order I sort of need to
define the opposite of it I need to
define a trivial state so what is a
trivial
state
so first a product
state is Trivial so if I have a whole
bunch of different spins or what have
you degrees of freedom and they're in a
and I'm just talking about pure States
at the moment we'll we'll talk about mix
stat you may wonder you know T greater
than zero mix States what does this mean
um I'm just going to talk about pure
States for a second um if you just have
each spin is pointing in some direction
uh in some product State this is a
trivial State also anything I can get
from a product state by a low depth
Quantum circuit low depth short range
Quantum circuit will also be considered
trivial so if I have some State I'll
draw it in one dimension that's a
product State like this and you can
apply some gates to
it
maybe you know you have a few rounds of
this Quantum circuit maybe the gates are
not even just acting on two cubits but
act on three at a time something like
that but as long as the quantum circuit
is uh has some bounds on its depth and
range acting on the initial State we
will also call this to be a trivial
State um this will also be considered to
be a trivial State um more precisely
okay so so uh Quantum circuit on
product
and for use later let me Define
something to be um R
trivial Rial will just mean that it can
be obtained from one of these Quantum
circuits with the range of the quantum
circuit being at most R what is the
range of the quantum circuit we'll sort
of look at how the range of each of
these unitaries and add it up over all
the rounds so sort of that's how much it
can spread out operators so R trivial
will say um the range of the
circuit
circuit so so so how would you define
this in a Contin because normally it's
with with Continuum no like with some
exponential Evolution that you can yeah
yeah I mean so so when we want to go to
the Continuum we will need to have a lot
of epsilons in terms of like truncating
things and so on so no I don't I don't
mean Continuum in space but continum and
time
uh um oh whether I would want to make
this by like a continuous time
Evolution right so so anything that we
obtain by continuous time Evolution we
can obtain up to Small error with one of
these continuous evolutions and then
like just as you mentioned in your intro
talk we sort of need to start worrying
about how big the errors are when we do
this and as I'm saying in this talk I'm
going to kind of gloss over all those
issues with what the epsilons are but
would kind of be related to
the it just says like that's basically
the lib Robin and velocity times the
time it's the range yeah so this is just
a measure of sort of you know that the
correlations can only have spread up to
this this range or or twice this
range but if we're so in an expander
graph would you say it's r or
exponentially an R uh in an
expander I mean so the range will be the
the number of Cubit oh no no it's just
the actual range sorry it's just the
literal range yeah so if I go and also
in every context in this talk I mean we
talk about R being basically fixed or
not fixed so you don't need to worry too
much is R like you know 10 or e to the
10 they're both of one
so okay so uh so so topological order
just means not trivial there is no
there's no trivial State that's the
ground state in fact there's no trivial
state that approximates the ground state
even if you take this R to be quite
large uh as long as the r is still small
compared to the system size
yeah of
States yes yeah yes so so so so so uh if
I go to T greater than zero I need to
have an appropriate definition for for
this and we can then then we can have
you convex so some some mixture of these
trivial States so um the remarkable
thing is that this thing has a property
of topological order at zero temperature
and no topological order above zero
temperature um
if I go to four dimensions you may
wonder why I'm going you know two and
four here and I'll maybe give some
intuition um there's another version of
the Tor code where you go to a four
dimensional lettuce and um the
remarkable thing is that this even has
topological
order for T smaller than some critical
temperature and again this critical
temperature is strictly positive dor can
you say exactly when you say no
topological order for T larger than zero
which does that mean for energy larg and
something you actually so you actually
do some you didn't really Define it
right no I didn't really Define it okay
I didn't really Define what it means to
have topological order for mix States uh
we can just say for a rough statement in
this talk uh topological order for mix
States means it's not trivial for mixed
States and a trivial mixed state is a
mixed state that it's a mixture of
trivial pure States good enough for good
enough for now again leaving out all the
epsilons and S it's a good defition
um okay yeah
um well okay so we would like to keep um
and I'm going to give a a more precise
statement to the quantum PCP conjecture
in a minute but I think we would like to
try keep it so that every spin interacts
with order one other spins whereas in a
hyper Cube they would interact with many
yeah otherwise we would be happy with
something like that you might also ask
about generalizations where each spin is
allowed to act interact with many other
spins but then rather than normalizing
the energy by the total the number of
spins you noriz by the total number of
terms in the hilon and so on but let me
just fix it that each spin should
interact with or or one other
spins
okay perhaps yeah I mean also for
Quantum things it sort of seems like
there's some results of uh AR Fernando
that I guess when you you know Ed spins
interacting with many spin sort of then
you can have some classical
approximation which will be then less
interesting for us so let me just for
this talk we'll we'll really be
interested in each spin interacts with
only order one and I'll put that in the
statement of the quantum PCP conjecture
in a minute all
right okay
uh questions okay um so this has top lot
Gorder for teeth smaller than uh first T
smaller than TC but it has um has low
energy
states
without top
water so
um a natural question is you know this
kind of looks like this if the analog of
top logical order is longrange order and
this one kind of looks like this one so
the question is is there a column that's
the analog of this column and the
conjecture that there's a column that's
or a row sorry a row that's the analog
of this Row the conjecture that there's
a row that's the analog of this row is
really going to take two different parts
first the part about is there something
with and I'll make this statement more
precise but we'll just say no low
energy trivial states that is there's
you know just as there's a system with
uh no low energy states that don't have
longrange parom magnetic order is there
a system where there are no um low
energy states that aren't topologically
ordered and uh similarly we could ask
about the analog of the sping glass
column sort of
remarkably
um the the the quantum thing if you're
looking at uh questions of um exact
ground state or approximation you know
to very high accuracy approximation of
the energy to one over polinomial
accuracy things already become qma hard
in one dimension
so in fact you actually uh Things become
quite hard even in 1D it's a little bit
funny in this case things get harder in
Quantum you don't have to go to as high
a dimension but one question will also
be is there something where hard to
approximate qma hard to approximate
and this will be the quantum PCP
conjecture so I'm going to sort of State
these two conjectures a little bit more
precisely and so the question is you
know what kind of system should we put
here instead of an expander graph and um
you know whether we can prove these two
properties Matt I think you add to TI
and tell us why the dimensions were even
um I will yeah I will talk a little bit
about that uh in a second um uh let me
maybe write these two conjectures before
I talk about that um but I will draw
your attention to one sort of
interesting theistic that related to the
fact that they even in some subance this
one is sort of like the square of this
one 2D is kind of like 1D s and 4D is
kind of like 2D s so this sort of
suggests that maybe what we should do is
look at something that's like an
expander graph squared in some in some
notion and I'll explain what that might
be um it's an interesting combinatorial
object I I should think by the way I
didn't mention my collaborator on a lot
of this is uh Mike fredman who is uh
also um so so especially in this work
I'll discuss that um that work with him
um so uh so good so so so um these these
conjectures here this this Quantum PCP
conjecture and no low energy trivial
States so uh Quantum PCP
conjecture font and PCP so the
conjecture is
conjecture so there exist a whole bunch
of
constants uh
d epon 1 which is smaller than Epsilon 2
C1 and
C2 such
that
given
hamiltonian with the following
properties one uh
every spin has Dimension at most
D dim M D um every spin is my no term
for sight or degree of freedom or
whatever sort of interchangeable um
every uh
term in h acts on at
most C1 spins so you know each each term
in h is going to act on o of one spins
you don't have any terms that act on
sort of unbounded number of spins but
every term acts on a bounded number uh
every
spin is acted
oned on by at most
C2 terms and uh so this is this is what
you were asking earlier I'm going to I'm
just going to restrict and say yeah
we'll just assume that each each one is
only participating in some bounded
number of terms rather than an unbounded
number I just want to oppose that Asen
if you're going to say that way I'm just
wondering L consider good
enough you know I would I would still
find this to be an extremely interesting
conjecture if there were a log in there
too um you'll have to slightly change
one thing in my final statement but I
would still find it to be an extremely
just a conjecture if it could be proven
yeah uh it's uh is there
no deduction well I mean the blackbox
would kind of be to make uh the terms in
the hamiltonian act on an unbounded
number of spins more than logarithmic
so so
um and uh every term has Norm one at
most
one uh has Norm
operator Norm at most one so the
hamiltan is a sum of these terms each
with thed Norm um and uh let e not be
the ground state energy so it's QA
hard qma
hard to
decide if e not is smaller than this
first constant Epsilon 1n or E not is
bigger than Epsilon 2 if to decide which
of these two is true promise that only
one of them is true um so if you want to
change it to the there can be uh by
construction here I have a most Order In
terms so you might be allowing since
you're allowing you might want grg you
might want to allow many terms acting on
a site you might want to change my n
here to be something that's the number
of terms rather than the number of sites
or something like that um anyway that's
the quantum PCP conjecture one
formulation and I guess a number of
people
um dofat Scott arenson uh several other
people not all of whom have their names
start but a right uh but I don't
remember all the names but many people
have thought about this question you
probably know the history much better so
many people have thought about it um and
uh we sort of have a a weaker um
conjecture that would that would have to
hold for this Quantum PCP conjecture and
this is a conjecture that uh my prevan
and I came up the no low energy trivial
States conjecture so before um stating
the conjecture the conjecture is simply
that a family of hamiltonians with this
property that I'll call nlts exist so
I'll just Define what this this property
is and then the conjecture is just that
such a family exists so uh
given
family h subn of hamiltonians so you
know H subn is a hamiltonian acting on N
spins uh we don't demand that they exist
for all n but they should exist for you
know a sequence of n that diverges
um uh again with uh
Dimension D is O of one
each
term acts on o1
sites site exactly the same as before
each site in O of one
terms um each
term has
Norm of one uh let's assume that the
minimum value is zero doesn't mean that
it's frustration free but uh we're just
going to you know just normalize it so
that the minimum wagon value is zero 8
has nlts this family has
nlts has
nlts
if um there exists an Epsilon that's
strictly greater than zero this is this
is going to be sort of the measure of
what low energy is such
that there does not exist an
R um such
that for all n uh
there is an R
trivial
State
s
with s expectation of the energy c hn c
smaller than Epsilon n so what does this
mean it's there's a whole bunch of does
not exist and so on so that means
there's some energy Epsilon so this is
the measure of low energy but if you
want to build a state for S which has
energy less than Epsilon time n I.E has
low energy according to this
approximation there's no way to do it as
an Rial state for a fixed r that will
work for all n you know you might maybe
do it with an r that diverges in some
way with n but there's no way to have a
single fixed r that works for all in in
the
family that does is that
clear that's that's clear but then if
you more things you include in your
family the less chance you have I mean
so can't you just create like an
artificial family where you include just
so many things that this won't have um
well you know again every term has to
act on at most of one sites every site
has to you know so currently we have
absolutely no idea how to prove well we
have some idea how to prove this
conjecture based on um I don't know how
much time I'll have left on some
topological ideas which I guess I'll
just consider the family of all
such of all such
um well no no no so so this family means
that well yeah yeah so so the family
means um for each for some set of n you
have some h of n so you give me a
sequence of hamiltonians I don't demand
it for every n but for a sequence that
goes to infinity and I I I don't think
there was an example I mean uh every
example we have we know how to do we
know how to make
this um and and the relation of this
no sorry yeah I don't know
so just to say it in one sentence it's
just that there exist tonians such that
below some energy all states are highly
intend that's the
conjecture so what would this Epson have
to be for the tood in four dimensions um
torod 40 is not n LTS I know but what
whole this a very interesting point I'm
going to talk about that in a second
although I'm probably going to run out
of time get in trouble let me talk about
that in one second well do you and
that's related to your question too
they're all kind of related yeah now if
you make our
logarithmic uh I don't know I don't know
I don't want to get too far off CH
that's a yeah I think maybe I have a
question related to the other I I want
to get some intuition about these low
eny stat anthropological order right
okay that's related to that I'm going to
get to that okay pause pause I'm going
to you you you're all GNA be much
happier in a
second but briefly I'm sure it's obvious
to everyone but uh how this and this
relate if you have a hamiltonian which
does have low energy trivial States if
it comes to deciding this kind of
approximation question um you can decide
the approximation question by using the
low energy State the trivial State as a
witness and for the trivial State you
can give a classical description you can
classically compute expectation so it
would not be Q hard it would only be NP
hard um yes the structure of the the
circuit that you assume uh to be R
trival does it respect the structure of
the graph not necessarily uh let's for
the moment assume it does you might
wonder about less local ones but let's
just use the metric on the graph to
measure
distances okay so many questions about
why 2D why um uh what the what the the
energy would have to be um in order to
do this so let me point out a very
important point and this is sort of
crucial to the like the main topological
point I wanted to discuss um which is I
I want to I want to pause briefly on the
questions unless there's like a serious
confusion usion um
so let me look at this 2D model here
suppose okay this is the whole the whole
sample you know hidden inside or many
bonds that I'm not drawing imagine we
kind of punch some holes out of it so
I'm going to draw these circles what I
mean by drawing these circles to say
punching some holes you know so the
lattice really has all these sights and
bonds and so on but around these holes
that I punch out I get rid of all the
interactions near these holes so I
punched some holes in here um now
this is going to give me a much more
efficient way of constructing trivial
States this is an interesting thing you
see if you just sort of thought naively
and thought how can I make a low energy
trivial state in 2D or in 4D you would
say well let's go back to that patch
construction let's take the lattice and
sort of cut it into patches like this
and then in each patch we can make an
exact state which will be R trivial with
an R that's of order L the size of the
patch and the energy would be of order
one L but I'm going to tell you that I
can do much better rather than cutting
out this whole line I can just cut out
sort of points on the corners and I'm
going to tell you that this state is
still far trivial for an R of order L
and I've paid much less energy price
what I mean by this by cutting out and
still R trivial means that I'll find an
exact round state of this hamiltonan
that's R trivial and since I've only
removed a few terms many fewer it will
be a much lower energy we'll have an
energy that's a order 1 over L squ
rather than one overl it's not to say
that you can actually find explicit no
no no well for the for the yeah yeah
actually you can for the toor codee for
the toor code yeah for the Tor code um
so the construction this relies on an
idea of Sergey bravy and collaborators
um and and the point that Sergey and
collaborators made is that if you have a
hamiltonian that's a sum of commuting
terms like this toric code is and every
term acts on at most two sites so
meaning I sort of have some graph of
sites and each term connects a pair of
sites then the ground state can be
written in an incredibly simple form
it's basically a classical state with
some entanglement between each site and
its neighbor along the cut uh I I won't
go into the details but sort ofis if you
have a single site that participates in
multiple bonds like this it's possible
to do some decomposition of the Hilbert
space on the site first some sort of
restriction to a Subspace and that's
where the classical information comes in
that's sort of how this problem remains
NP hard once you restrict to the
Subspace you can then Factor the problem
into three distinct degrees of freedom
that couple each way so you can make a
unary on each site after you restrict to
the Subspace on each site that then
completely factors the problem like this
and you find that there are uh just now
degrees of freedom that only talk to
each other like this so it's it's R
trivial for an R that's order one it's a
very very simple ground state and here I
can course grain I can take all the
sites inside this big region and group
them into one site I can take all the
sites in this region and group them into
one site and so on so I can do this and
now what I find is that this super sight
interacts with this super sight and so
on but the interaction of super sites is
now too local it's just this one to this
one or this one to this one there's
nothing that acts on this this and this
all at the same time so it's much
simpler problem so actually I can get
away with a much lower um lower energy
and still have trivial state in this
case now this also answers your question
why I had to go to 2D if I were in 1 D I
can always cor grain to this at least if
I stick to these commuting hamiltonians
which are the ones we understand better
so so certainly I have to start in 2D to
make things
interesting um so this gives us some
hint that what we want to look for is we
want to look for something where you
can't Co grain it to Wy you also can't
Co grain it to something that's treel
likee so putting the hamiltonian on an
expander graph you know if you just had
an expander graph but each term was only
coupling Neighbors on the expander graph
this will be no good this will give us a
trivial state so an expander graph won't
be no good we need something where the
hamiltonian involves terms that act on
more than two sites but we also want
something where we can't coar granted to
act on more than two sites you know to
act on only two sites so for example if
we drew just to give a kind of uh you
know funny example suppose we've had a
situation
where
um I took an expander graph but every
time I had a bond between two sites I
kind of replaced it with this
complicated structure and then in the
term the hilon involved all three things
in these triangles rather than just
paral interactions I can now course
grain it combine these two sites into
one and now suddenly it's back to the
original situation so I want something
that I can't Co grain to the to the
expander graph so I have some very
strong requirements I want something
where I can't course grain it to two
local I want something where I can't
remove a few degrees of freedom and then
course grain it to two local and um
because if I could do that with removing
only a few degrees of freedom then we'
be done now actually um there's some
some technical details though we don't
fully have the following statement but
we have it in a lot of situations that
there's even some cases where even if
you can locally course grain it to two
local but not globally you can still
show it as a trivial State there's some
technical assumptions you need there and
I won't explicitly State what the
differences due to time constraints um
but uh the the hint then is that we
really want things where yeah it's sort
of very
much not too local there's no way to
make it Tre like there's no way to
remove a few things or coar grain to
make a tree like so we're kind of
looking for manifolds or graphs with a
very special property and I'll try to
make that property a little more precise
and show what they are and argue that
that's a good higher dimensional
generalization of um the expander
graph so there is a term in graph Theory
called yeah I know I'm running no no I
think we started late so how well what's
your well I can plan s 10 minutes or
something yeah yeah okay 10 minutes is
good yeah 10 minutes is good okay um so
there's a term in graph Theory called
hyperfinite
and I want to talk briefly about this
term before giving the generalization of
this and then showing that things exist
uh which are sort of meet some general
which fail to meet some generalization
this and then argue that they're a good
place to look um so what is uh
hyperfinite mean in graph Theory hyper
is closely related to expansion but it's
not quite the same thing so a
it's not a property of a graph it's a
family of
graphs is
hyper uh if for all Epsilon greater than
zero you can remove an Epsilon fraction
of the of the
cells of the let's say of the uh of the
vertices and then remove all the
attached
edges uh and the remaining graph becomes
disconnected um uh oh sorry I left out
for all Epsilon greater than Z I left
out if there exists an R there exists an
R so that you can move an Epsilon
fraction of the vertices and graph um
becomes
disconnected regions of size
R disconnected graphs of diameter
R so meaning you take out a small amount
and then um you know then it becomes
just some disconnect disconnected graphs
of this certain diameter
um and this has to hold for every graph
in the family that is there's for every
Epsilon greater than zero there's some R
that will work for every single graph in
the family so um to give an example of a
hyperfinite graph if you took a square
lattice a a family of square laes of
increasing size this would be
hyperfinite because um if you tell me
you know Epsilon is 0 01 I'll just say
okay yeah you know I'm going to take
some Some Cuts like this and cut
everything along these cuts and then
then each of these patches has some
bounded radius and I've removed a
certain fraction so there's a way of
disconnecting it by removing a small
amount and this is very closely tied to
this this classical side
um expander graphs would not be
hyperfinite there would be no way to to
do this a family of expander graphs
would not be hyper so um what what we
came up with is we came up with a
generalization of this definition that
we think captures a lot of where you
want to look so
um instead of talking about grass if
becomes meaningful now to talk about um
complexes so instead of a graph has some
vertices which are like zero dimensional
objects zero cells in the language of
simplical complexes edges which are like
one cells so graph is just a one complex
in this language but also you can start
talking about oh yeah I also want to add
in some uh you know fill in some of
these faces that these would be called
two cells and then you might have some
higher dimensional objects like three
cells that would be volume and so on and
there's certain rules for how you can
glue it together and this is this is a
description of such an object so
um uh so what we came up with is a
notion of um K hyperfinite so we say if
we have a family not of graphs but a
family of some L complexes what L
complexes meaning you have cells up to L
so a graph is a one complex it has some
some vertices and some edges a two
complex will also have some two
dimensional cells and so on like this so
um so L complexes so we'll have some L
something will be Kyper finite for a k
less than L um if for all Epsilon
greater than Z there exists an R so that
you can remove an Epsilon fraction of
the zero
cells and all the attached higher cells
too and then what is this analog of
disconnected well the analog of
disconnected is that it becomes K
dimensional and what does it mean
becomes K dimensional and so the
complex can be
mapped continuously
do a k
complex why it's K hyper
finite with the diameter of the
pre-images of this map bounded by
R IAM a
pre-image at most are so what does this
what does this mean let me you know give
some sort of intuitive notion so in the
case of zero hyperfinite zero
hyperfinite is hyperfinite in the graph
Theory language why is that well for for
example after this is um after I remove
all these sites here I have this patch
here and I can just say well I'll take
the function which takes this patch and
Maps this whole patch to a single point
and I do that for each patch so I maed
every patch to a point all left with is
a collection of points which is a zero
complex and the diameter of the
pre-image is just the diameter of each
of these patches so the the the the this
thing is zero hyperfinite any
hyperfinite graph it's the same as
saying it's zero hyperfinite um
so what would it be to be one hyperfit
well as I as I said earlier you know if
we consider a family of expander graphs
this is not zero hyperfinite there's no
way to remove a small fraction and make
it hyperfinite but imagine we took each
of these edges and we sort of thickened
it into a a small tube like that so you
know you add in then some cells going
around the edge of the tube uh and then
fill in the surfaces of those cells so
it's really like a two-dimensional
surface and then similarly here and of
course you know we then
attach all these uh tubes to a sphere
for each vertex um so this would be some
too complex but it would be one hyper
fenet this family gener you know if we
take a fix family of expander graphs and
then do this thickening construction
because I can take each of these edges
and just map them down to a single line
and I can take each of these spheres and
map it to a single point and that's map
this thing down to uh um a uh one
complex and I didn't even need to remove
anything I was actually able to do it
for Epsilon equals z just for positive
upsite um so so so so so for example
these things this is sort of closely
tied to this property that you can coar
grain things and make them look like a
tree so we believe that what you want to
look at is you want to look at um
complexes which have a property of not
being one hyperfinite things which are
sort of intrinsically two-dimensional in
some sense if I want to sort of be a
little bit poetic it means that you know
in the in the in the classical language
what you kind of have is that an
expander graph particles diffuse very
well and it's this great diffusion of
particles that means that when you cut
out a small fraction of points the
information is still carried but in the
quantum setting we really wanted that
something where strings can diffuse very
well where it's very hard to come up
with a barrier to string motion if I
want to sort of think back to this
language where I talked about removing a
few points from the square lattice what
happens is that when I remove a few
points from the square lattice sort of a
string can get hung up around one of
these points and become unable to move
well and the only way the string can
kind of move is to extend sort of amiba
like tendil but it can't really sweep
out an area so I kind of look for
complexes on which um which are not one
hyperfinite where the strings can move
very freely where even if you punch out
a few points the strings can get around
them you know so like think in three
dimensions if I remove a single point in
three dimensions a string can happily
just go around it you know but if I
remove a line in three dimensions that
can succeed to pin the string so I need
something where there's no way to remove
points and yet stop the string motion um
and so this is this is exactly what
looking for so I'll tell you these
things do exist yes do can you clarify a
little bit more why is it the right
thing to look at Spring motions that's
kind of the intuitive idea the more
precise you know formulation comes from
both this idea um of of course graining
to two local and then the fact that
sometimes even when you can locally
course grain to two local it's enough um
so why are you just interested in
strings oh yeah yeah no so so this this
separate question yes really indeed we
should have a more stringent requirement
that depending upon the code maybe we
are worried about surfaces or higher
dimensional objects so
um let me try and answer that and
take three more minutes and finish and
then I'll then I'll stop talking yeah so
maybe you don't want to get into this
but I wonder how much of this is
specialized to the meeting case because
I don't know in the non-meeting case we
can this seems like it's deeply about
being complexes and not graphs but in
the non-com meting case yes if PCP is
equivalent to the two to the version on
graphs yeah yeah I don't know I don't
know uh I think this is easier to think
about for me at least but uh certainly
yeah and we could ask you know are these
things true I didn't require in these
conjectures that'd be commuting hilon
but yeah um okay
um yeah last last thing I was going to
say so how do you both prove that these
objects exist and sort of answer your
question about which ones I should deal
with basically the way you prove that
they exist is you knowe that um to prove
that for example there exists um
something that's not one hyperfinite how
I construct such a family of manifolds
whose triangulation will give me uh
something that's not one hyper finite um
the key the key is to look at uh the
Betty number so what I can do is is uh
you can construct various
um uh manifolds for example
four-dimensional hyperbolic manifold
compact four dimensional hyperbolic
manifold so the second Betty number can
be made to be proportional to the system
size so that the second Betty number is
extend ensive so first Betty number sort
of counts the number of non-trivial
Loops in there the second Betty number
is sort of some analogous thing for
surfaces so you can come up with
something where by a counting another
one that will do it and this gets back
to sort of my original analogy is
expander graph crossed with itself
there's a way of constructing a complex
which is the basically the square of the
expander graph again that has extensive
second Betty number and you can show
sort of two things very roughly that
removing zero cells only drops the Betty
number by one so removing if you have an
extensive Betty number and you remove a
small fraction of Z cells you're still
with a nonzero Betty number second Betty
number and then that is an obstruction
to mapping it um in this case to mapping
it onto a one complex so this gives us a
construction of these things and it
relies on these higher Betty numbers but
the important thing then is also that
sort of um in the 40 Tor code we might
have uh both worry about surfaces um but
we might also want to worry about sort
of um
uh uh you know um lines or
um uh or or volumes or whatever and so
different ones will depend upon
different Med Betty numbers so it seems
that a lot of the important construction
might be to find something where you
don't just have an extensive Betty
number in the middle Dimension but
outside the middle Dimension and so the
suspicion is that if such could be
constructed that this would be a way to
um really uh uh come up with the example
that once you construct that family of
manifolds then you can just put the code
on it and you've got you solve the nlts
so I think I'm getting pretty far field
and I'm basically out of top
St okay are there questions right now
one question there many
questions uh so are these things related
to you know
Alexi and people around him have this
notion of high dimensional expanders
yeah I know there's several Notions of
higher dimensional expanders I think
this is a distinct notion of higher
dimensional expanders yet another one so
I think there several that are not
equivalent I think this is another one I
hopefully it'll be interesting to
comment
l so I guess um speaking as a condensed
matter person I was a little unclear on
what the motivation was is this an
important end result or end goal in
information Theory I would say this
would be um okay I can give you two
answers to that I think the computer
scientists would say that this is a very
important end goal probably yeah
maybe okay if if I'm to answer I think
that I I don't know if this is the end
goal but I think that it just sort of
connects many many beautiful questions
about the nature of inang and nature of
topological order that it sort of
highlights them and isolates them in a
very beautiful way so so to me you know
they sort of the computer scientists of
course came up with all this conjecture
unless the a classical case to me the
the interesting thing is that when I
first heard this conjecture I said this
is obviously false for Quantum systems
and the sort of the intuition was that
well nonzero temperature somehow
entanglement should only be up to some
length scale because I'm at non-zero
temperature but then you start getting
into questions like well of course the
40 Tor code does have long- range
entanglement but only not that much of
it at non-zero temperature but then you
also get sort of up to questions of yeah
well what would it mean that if I sort
of understood local density matrices of
the system could I reconstruct the
global state so it seemed to get at a
lot of interesting questions of uh
reconstruction of global state from
local information so that was why I
liked
it this is a unrelated question that was
also bothering me that the received
wisdom said for for thermalizing States
all excited states have volume low
entanglement so what does it mean to say
that there are low entanglement States
well certainly not all I mean there may
be a question about what the igen states
are of certain uh non- inscribable
systems but certainly there are states
of low energy that are not very intang
for all these
systems other yeah so was not quite
clear so at the end uh what the the
question about commuting versus not
commuting so so could it be that that
these hon are only consist of computing
terms uh so
so my guess would be that if this n
energy trivial States is true which I'm
starting to believe maybe that one
probably is true but that might be true
just when we restrict to commuting
certainly will be much easier to analyze
um but it's enough it would be enough to
look at points I I don't know I mean I
don't have any theorem that says that if
it's true it has to be true for
commuting or anything like that but
intuitively I think in that case it's
probably enough to look for commuting
but for the qma hardness which I then
don't think is true but if it were true
you probably would need to look Beyond
commuting but there are just very vague
intuition so related question that so
the exact claim is that if it is
commuting that it ought to be a k hyper
finite complex so what is the exact
claim oh well no the claim is that um if
I have I can't quite prove the following
statement but I can prove it if you give
me one or two extra technical
assumptions that if it's commuting and
it's one hyperfinite then it has low
energy trivial States I can't quite
prove that I can prove it with a couple
extra technical assumptions and I would
believe that it's true in general so
let's look for things that are commuting
and are not one hyperfinite it sort of
seems so intuitive too that we should
look for something where you know the
the strings can move very freely and so
since we we now have these examples we
should look we should look to them as a
then is there a merit to distinguishing
between two hyperf
there there maybe yeah this gets to the
the question over there of like you know
what about lines or surfaces or so on
because the point is that with the toic
code you know when I put the toor code
in a certain Dimension like two
Dimension um or in two Dimension there's
there's sort of these these two kind of
loop operators that both have Dimension
One and so for the the the thing to be
interesting it would have to not be uh
one hyper it have to be at least two
dimensional so depending upon what your
Loop operators are you know if you put a
certain code down where you have things
of Dimension four and dimension five you
might want it you know that that will
tell you what not hyperfinite it should
be so so yeah you you you also want
these higher ones but the higher ones
are also not so hard to construct so for
example you could take the cube or the
fourth power of the expander graph and
that will give you you know higher
powers of this by the same bet number
argument but it would be really funny if
let's say for 23 or the sudden you would
have any construction and for 22 you
wouldn't so it I mean you you fear that
it either stops at two or three or yeah
I mean I can imagine that you might want
to go yeah maybe not just two or three
but me two three four something small
because in some cases you know because
you sort of wind up doubling some of the
dimension because the two degrees of
freedom the the electric and magnetic
have uh and then maybe not things don't
interesting don't happen in the first so
maybe you have to go up to four or
something but yeah probably not like
forever but you did say your result
you're one-sided in oh I didn't say that
yeah okay so last thing I mentioned
since story desk um one thing that's
interesting is that if you look at the
graph cross graph which is this expander
graph squared um we don't yet have a
construction of nlts on it but we prove
that if you put the Tor code on that it
has sort of a one-sided version that if
you force no error in the electric or
magnetic depending upon your notation
then there's no way to obtain a trivial
state with low error in the other side
so you sort of can't go allow error in
both but you can allow error in one but
not the other it's one specific one
there's one it's not either one but is
there a unique way of putting this T
code on expander graph or there's
different there's probably different so
if you just put the Tor code on the
expander graph it's sort of not so
interesting because there's only two
cells Zer so there's no plaque head
operators but if you put the torque code
on graph C graph is quite
interesting
maybe believe the nlts I I would believe
nlts but not believe PCP but you don't I
don't know I don't know but I mean I'm
not sure on either
one okay well maybe we
should